these hands can catch anything okay that  was rigged for the record I'm catching  all of them  I know I got soul fans let's make them a  little bit softer Dove brought me out  they want me to catch a bunch of things  I'm walking in I'm saving their Legos  fruit  I'm ready to rock and roll  let's do this was it always this windy  today it feels like it just picked up  now  got it got it  it's a tea party  men's care too  slime what'd you guys even get slime  and it feels yucky and disgusting  [Music]  that's a catch  not the best way you want to catch the  bear but we'll take it  ah  that's great send more  for the record I'm catching all of them  still got one thank you for the throws  man appreciate it be good I told you  guys to catch everything I took care of  my hands now it's time to hydrate  everything else with Dove men's hand and  body lotion soft hands on the field even  softer hands off it